that right there is a rare royal pda
moment yeah we're very excited prince
william and kate middleton are
displaying their affection for one
another in a stunning new black and
white photo from sunday's inaugural
earthshot prize awards in london you can
see kate sweetly resting her hand on her
husband's back as he leans down to talk
to her in another pic from the event
shared on the couple's joint instagram
william looks back at kate who was all
smiles as they walk through a curtain
but wait there's more take a look at
this solo shot of the duke who appears
to be taking in the moment backstage
when we launched the prize last year our
ambition was to find the most innovative
solutions to the world's greatest
environmental challenges prince william
launched the earthshot prize earlier
this year as part of his and kate's
ongoing environmental advocacy efforts
to celebrate green activism the duke and
duchess wore recycled formal wear to the
occasion and they looked good william
was dashing in a green velvet blazer
which she paired with a black turtleneck
in black trousers and kate looked
flawless in a flowing lilac gown with a
beaded belt by alexander mcqueen and get
this it's actually a gown that she's
previously worn to the 2011 bafta bridge
to watch event in los angeles
in other royal news queen elizabeth ii
cancels her official trip to northern
ireland due to doctor's orders a
spokesperson for buckingham palace said
in a statement on wednesday that the
queen accepted her physician's advice to
rest for the next few days adding quote
her majesty is in good spirits and is
disappointed that she will no longer be
able to visit northern ireland where she
had been due to undertake a series of
engagements today and tomorrow a source
tells et that the 95 year old british
monarch has had a packed schedule
recently and the cancellation of her
trip to ireland quote is not covet
related and as for the queen's
whereabouts well our source says that
she's taking her doctor's advice and
resting at windsor castle and echoes
that she is indeed in good spirits